what have you got me into i've got this  i don't think you have  911 what's your emergency  hello are you there  dad i hit somebody  and i left him i left him there  oh my god don't tell anyone  not ever i can do this i can keep you  safe if no one ever hears about it  the boy you hit this morning is jimmy  baxter's son  the head of the most vicious crime  family in the city  whoever you are wherever you are  you will be found  i need a favor no questions asked  it wasn't a hidden run it was a hit  there's no other explanation  so if you want a war i'll give you a war  we go big we go big once  my best friend just threw me in the deep  end i've got this  i don't think you have  i promise you it's going to be all right  you